la brigada de represión de los delitos
contra las personas inició hoy una
investigación por acoso sexual y moral
en contra de la hora suspendido
presidente de la federación francesa de
fútbol Noel recordemos que esta
investigación se origina en las
denuncias de Sonia Suite Ella es una
representante de jugadoras y denunció
justamente por acoso sexual al dirigente
frente a una comisión que realiza una
auditoría interna en la federación
francesa de fútbol no alegre fue
suspendido el pasado 11 de enero hasta
que esta investigación termine
recordemos que también es auditoría
tiene que ver con las declaraciones que
él hizo en contra de zinedine Zidane el
Antiguo jugador de la selección en
francesa y también entrenador de fútbol
consultado en una radio legré sobre la
posibilidad de que Zidane fuera a
entrenar al equipo de Brasil él dijo que
no le interesaba incluso que si sinedine
Zidane lo llamaba él no iba a contestar
el teléfono
legré justamente reaccionó a este
encausamiento a través de un comunicado
de prensa enviado la agencia afp dijo
primero estar sorprendido de enterarse
de la noticia por la prensa desmintió
todo acoso sexual o moral y más bien
acusó a la ministra de deportes de
presiones políticas en contra de esa
comisión de investigación interna de la
federación francesa de fútbol